يعود الصخبوا الى هذه القريه البدويه
الهادئه
يراقب ابو العز المشهد وقد عاد خوف
التهجير يعتريه دون ان يفهم لماذا فهو
وعائلته يعيشون على هذه الثلاث الصخريه
منذ نحو 70 عاما ولم يسبق ان اعتدوا او
اضروا بحياه احد
قلنا مثلا
فيها اكثر من 70 سنه شايف يعني من قبل من
سنه الخمسين واحنا موجودين هاجرونا اول
مره من العراق
واليوم ضاقت عليهم صار بدهم يقوم البدو من
هذا المحل على مقلوبه من ابو العز عشرات
من الناشطين الفلسطينيين يرفعون الرايات
ويهتفون ضد الهدم والاخلاء وعلى التله
المقابله نواب وكنيست من حزب النقود برفقه
قواته من الشرطه والامن الاسرائيليه
يتظاهرون لتعجيل اخلاء القريه وتهجيري
اهلها هي بوابه القدس الشرقيه هي وكل هذه
التجمعات المحيطه من هنا حتى البحر الميت
مخطط المشروع المشروع يعني لف هذه المنطقه
بعد اخلاء هذه المناطق من التجمعات
الفلسطينيه بحزام السيطاني حول مدينه
القدس
المتجدد باقامه القدس الكبرى
في قريه الخان الاحمر يعيش 180 بدويه روح
له في خمسينيات القرن الماضي من منطقه
النقب وفي القريه مدرسه تخدم باقي
التجمعات في المنطقه وقد صدر قبل اربع
سنوات قرار من المحاكم الاسرائيليه بهدم
القريه ونقل سكانها لكن الضغوط الدوليه
على الحكومات الاسرائيليه المتعاقبه حاله
دون تنفيذ القرار
خطر الهدم والاخلاء يعود ليخيم على هذه
القريه البدويه اكثر من اي وقت مضى لاسيه
وان هناك وزراء في حكومه نتنياهو باتو
يربطون وجودهم ضمن الائتلاف الحكومي
بانهاء وجود هؤلاء السكاني على ارضهم من
قريه الخان الاحمر عبد الحفيظ جعوان
العربيه الاراضي الفلسطينيه